for every acclaimed action movie there
are a dozen more that were shredded by
critics can fairness a lot of those
films probably deserve their lousy
rotten tomato scores after all making an
action movie is no easy task and you
need more than a couple of explosions to
create an awesome film on the other hand
Rotten Tomatoes is a website that lacks
nuance and sometimes you might find an
adrenaline laced gem under all those
slimy green splotches from films with
monstrous snakes to gigantic gods these
action movies might have terrible tomato
meters but they're still worth watching
plagued by production woes and a
whitewashing controversy The Lone Ranger
was in trouble from day one and granted
Gore Verbinski's film is a mess but in a
way that's what makes it so fascinating
there are so many ideas at play here
from the exploitation of Chinese
laborers and the genocide of Native
Americans to the takeover of American
politics by corrupt corporations the
cinematography is sweeping and beautiful
and some of the sets feel like they were
taken from a baz lurman movie while the
decision to cast Johnny Depp as Tonto
may have been culturally insensitive he
is actually hilarious and he has real
chemistry with the charming army hammer
if you could just point us in the right
direction we'll take it from here what's
that nothing while it's no Pirates of
the Caribbean
The Lone Ranger doesn't deserve its bad
reputation and proves even the messiest
movies have a silver lining
set in the Amazon jungle anaconda is a
big dumb monster flick that traffic's
and b-movie scares and we mean that in
the best possible way it follows a group
of documentary filmmakers led by
Jennifer Lopez who run into the world's
biggest and hungriest snake the creature
Yanks its victims underwater snatches
them out of the air and never seems to
get its fill of human flesh and while
it's occasionally done with silly CG
there's also a fantastic animatronic
snake that looks like it escaped from an
evil rainforest cafe but the serpent
isn't even the highlight of the movie
the real draw is Jon Voight as a smarmy
poacher with an untraceable accent he'll
ears and sneers every second he's on
camera all the while plotting ways to
catch the killer reptile even if that
means using human bait you should just
ignore the cynical critics
and anaconda because they're just trying
to squeeze all the fun out of the cinema
2006 is Tokyo Drift is the black sheep
of the Fast and Furious franchise Paul
Walker is nowhere to be found
Vin Diesel only shows up for a few
seconds and the undercover cops and
international heists are replaced by a
soapy teenage melodrama the plot follows
a troubled American kid named Sean who
moves to Japan gets involved with the
Yakuza and is forced to race the local
bully to save his buddies his girlfriend
and his own honor of course before he
can become the king of the road this
hotshot has to learn how to drift in
other words it's the Karate Kid with
cars
[Music]
watching these hot rods drift their way
down mountain roads is pretty impressive
and even kind of beautiful on top of all
that Tokyo Drift introduces some key
players to the F&F franchise actors sun
kang director justin lin and writer
chris morgan these guys would be
instrumental in shaping the series going
forward but even as its own movie Tokyo
Drift is a slick looking film with fun
races and characters we care about
guy ritchie is best known for making
comedic crime thrillers which would seem
to make him a weird pick to direct King
Arthur legend of the sword and
admittedly there are parts of this film
that are a chore to sift through but you
can't deny its ambition especially when
the monsters roll onto the screen there
are war elephants to tower over castles
and then we watch as a massive writhing
tentacles reveal slimy witches that are
part woman part Kraken we kept outside
of the Covenant it was you lost the boy
and the soul sacrifice too no but
there's more going on here than just
high fantasy Richie brings his trademark
humor to the film and almost every
character acts like a cockney criminal
making King Arthur legend of the sword a
wonderfully weird way to spend a
Saturday afternoon
tell me story about a goko Lucy a Viking
called grey bid of some rebel graffiti
duty in these worlds are you writing a
book
critics hated bright in fact they
loathed it and you know what it's
totally understandable bright has a lot
of problems from its lazy world-building
and sloppy screenplay to it's awkward
handling of racial issues but while it
doesn't live up to its potential it's
nevertheless filled with striking images
like a cent or cop and a dragon flying
over Los Angeles and while the story
mechanics and character arcs are messy
David Ayer knows how to direct an action
scene the gas station shootout is a
highlight and the moment when Will Smith
saves his orc partner from a gang of
murderous cops is wonderfully done but
the best thing about bright has got to
be Joel Edgerton who plays the first orc
ever hired to work for the LAPD he
wonderfully conveys pain underneath all
his prosthetics and you should check out
bright for his performance alone he
fulfills a great prophecy would I think
we might be in a prophecy Universal
Studios has been trying to create a
monstrous cinematic universe for quite
some time before The Mummy completely
unraveled in 2017 the studio was hoping
to get its dark universe going with
Dracula untold in 2014 unfortunately
lousy box office numbers and a poor
tomato meter forced the studio to stake
this film in the heart but while it's
not a great movie by any stretch of the
imagination Dracula untold is
wonderfully dumb fun it's basically a
vampire movie meets a superhero flick
directed by Gary Shore Dracula untold
finds Luke Evans as the titular
bloodsucker only instead of trying to
murder innocent women
this Dracula is an undead superhero
trying to protect his homeland from
invading Turks this dark tale truly
shines when Dracula is beating up bad
guys he plows into a platoon of goons
like a mad NFL player
all while roaring like a lion and using
force like powers he commands a legion
of bats to batter his enemies he even
creates his own vampire army resulting
in a brilliantly bloody climax this
isn't high art but if you've ever
wondered what would happen if Dracula
used his bat powers for good then this
is the movie for you
Boyko sick isn't it save me yes and I
would do it all again directed by James
Wan death sentence says the gore of saw
the scares of the conjuring and the
family feels of Furious 7
in fact we're legitimately shocked that
it has such a low tomato meter unlike
most of the films on this list there are
no obvious reasons why it was blasted so
hard by critics instead this 2007
revenge thriller is gritty gross and
utterly compelling
with its opening montage of home video
footage we're rooting for Nik Hume from
frame 1 he's a good dad and a loving
husband so naturally he's devastated
when his oldest son is murdered by a
machete-wielding gangster when Nik
realizes the legal system is going to
let the killer off easy
he takes justice into his own hands but
what starts off as a simple act of
revenge spirals into full-on war when
the criminals brother comes back for
blood Kevin Bacon is the key to the
movie's success he's not some Charles
Bronson super vigilante he's a real
human being struggling with guilt and
grief he barely knows how to use a gun
and he breaks down into tears after
murdering his son's killer you really
feel the love this guy has for his
family and his hatred for the thugs who
threatened his home in addition to bacon
there's John Goodman as an F bomb
dropping force of nature who Selznick
his cache of weapons in the best gun
buying scene since
taxi driver dad - dad don't tell me
about it just go do it
it all caps off with one of cinema's
most underrated gunfights an epic battle
awash in red light death sentence is a
badass bloody affair that proves Rotten
Tomatoes can sometimes get it wrong
2016's gods of Egypt was lambasted for
its Eurocentric cast cheesy acting and
shabby CGI but it's over-the-top
performances and bizarre look should
actually make it worth your while said
in ancient Egypt the plot follows a
human thief who's caught a struggle
between two larger-than-life deities
this mythological conflict takes our
characters into outer space before
plunging them into the underworld while
the movie is absolutely bonkers when it
comes to the visuals it also somehow
still plays everything perfectly
straight there's no cynical winking or
annoying irony so if you enjoy big
hearted adventures then gods of Egypt
will be good for your soul
it's easy to see why Hansel and Gretel
witch hunters has such a low tomato
meter it's mostly because of Hansel and
Gretel
they don't have character arcs their
dialogue is flat and there's nothing
distinguishing them from one another
besides the fact that one is played by
Jeremy Renner and the other by Gemma
Arterton really they're just two
badasses who run around and blow up
witches yeah yeah yeah
how do you do - Nathan candy but if
you're into seeing evil creatures
getting their heads cut off
then Hansel and Gretel witch hunters is
the movie for you this 2013 horror
adventure is like army of Darkness on
crack
complete with anachronistic weapons
buckets of blood and more wicked old
hags than you can shake a broomstick in
the monster makeup is on point and the
flying effects are both creepy and cool
and while Renner and Arterton aren't
doing a lot with their characters femke
Johnson more than makes up for it as the
villainous head witch geez big she's bad
she's over-the-top glorious and Peter
Stormare plays a sheriff bringing the
smarm for everyone to hate granted
watching Renner punch women in the face
is a bit unsettling but for the most
part The Kills here are creative if
you're in the mood for a movie that's
lost its mind this witchy flop is for
you
[Music]